-Our first guest tonight i
a very funny comedian and acto
you know from his work
in "Breaking Bad,"
"The Mandalorian," and
"The King of Staten Island."
He's the host of the
"Monday Morning Podcast,"
with new episodes streamin
twice a week.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Bill Burr.
How are you, Bill?
-What's going on, Seth?
Nice to see you.
-It's nice to see you, as well
I wish you were here in person
Bill, you are
a famously optimistic man.
How are you feeling about
life going back to normal
now that we have vaccines
out there?
-Well, I mean,
I think, you know,
hopefully most people
will take the vaccine.
And I think people who don't -
I don't know.
At some point, you know,
you're either with us
or you're against us.
You know, like, if you hav
a divided locker room,
you can't win a championship
Like, I just --
You know, I don't know.
Somebody's got to
do a show called
"The Adventures
of the Internet Doctor."
These people who haven't
gone to medical school,
yet they somehow --
You'd be like, "Oh, yeah,
Johnson & Johnson has --"
"Oh, they don't know what th
hell they're talking about."
It's like, "Dude,
you drive a tow truck.
Why would I listen to you
about this?"
So I'm gonna take it.
You know, I'm gonna
roll the dice, whatever.
We'll see what happens.
I am a little ticked off
that it, like --
it only lasts a year.
-Right.
-That's when I'm kind of
being like, "Oh, I get it.
This is that corporate thing."
"We could sell 7 billion
or 7 billion every year."
It's like, just can you
turn up the power
and just cure the damn thing
Can you just do that, please
-Have you noticed a difference
under the Biden administration
with the vaccine rollout?
Do you think it's better
post the Trump administration?
-Well, I think all those guy
work for the same people.
I think that's why
Trump got out,
as much as they're trying to act
like it was a progressive thing.
The thing about it is, is no one
could make money with that guy
'cause you didn't know
what the hell he was gonna do.
He was a wild card.
He was a gunslinger.
Like, I don't understand how war
is still legal in 2020,
how that's still, like,
an acceptable adult way
that two countries
solve their differences.
And as much as everybody
thinks that Democrats
are these
"We Are the World" people,
they sort of told a lie
when it comes to that,
just like the so-called
evil Republicans.
So I'm kind of, like,
right in the middle.
I'm not in the middle.
I'm standing outside all of it
I learned a lot by listening
to George Carlin,
and I think he was way ahead o
his time, and he was 100% right.
Put it that way.
-It's interesting
you mention George Carlin
and being ahead of his time,
because you produced
a documentary
about your friend
Patrice O'Neal,
who was a stand-up comedia
that I know to comedians
was incredibly well-respected,
incredibly well-loved
and maybe not fully embraced
by an audience
before he tragically passed.
-No, he was the greatest
comedian live I've ever seen
Ever, and that guy was
so far beyond all of us,
and there's no way
in just this segment
to try to sum up the enormit
of his talent
and the loss
of him dying so young.
I mean, he was the guy
that just --
He turned comedians who --
We never shut up.
He turned us all
into audience members.
He would hold court onstage,
offstage.
He was just killing
everywhere he went,
and he could do anything
from just silliness
to social commentary.
He just had --
You know, it's something
I'll never get over,
to be honest with you.
Beyond being a friend,
just as a fan of stand-up
and seeing all of the crazines
and, you know,
the double standards and stuff
that he could have had fun with.
I mean, the first thing
I remember when he passed away
that I was like, "God, I would
have loved to hear his take,
was that Sandusky interview.
You know?
I don't know how, but he would
have somehow, with pedophilia,
gotten a new half-hour.
And would have
had people laughing
at something they didn't
want to laugh at.
Just to not see him --
You know, like, he would
have eloquently been able
to say what I just said, whereas
me, I just say it bluntly.
What are you gonna do to me,
Seth?
I do stand-up
in parking lots now
outside of The Magic Castle,
and I'm thrilled.
I actually look at the cars.
I like to see an even amount
of, like, Priuses and SUVs
so it's a nice, balanced
liberal and conservative crowd
-Oh, that's interesting.
You can tell
by the make of the car
how balanced your audience i
these days.
-Yeah. Too many Teslas,
it's like,
"Alright, these people
aren't attached."
That's my big thing
with Joe Biden.
Before we get involved
with this Iran stuff,
I just wish he would take a ride
in a Tesla.
And just realize that there'
other ways to, you know,
deal with whatever
the problem is over there.
I don't understand why
we can have nuclear weapon
and other people can't.
I don't get that.
-So you think a ride in a Tesl
would be beneficial to Joe Biden
because he would --
less reliant on sort of
oil-producing nations?
-Yeah.
What you got to do
is get in one of those things,
have two kids in the back
and your wife there
and have somebody in, like
a Porsche sitting next to you.
And you just put it in,
what do they call it,
Insanity, Lunacy mode,
and you just blow them off the
line with groceries in the back.
It's hilarious.
I guess gas-combustion peopl
are like,
"Yeah, well,
after 80 miles an hour..."
It's like,
"Where are you doing 80?"
There's people driving aroun
with their kids, you lunatic
Go to a track if that's
what you want to do.
-I have a lot to ask you
about the Super Bowl.
And I'm gonna do that
when we come right back
with more from Bill Burr.